ahead of a decisive European summit on
the UK's negotiations on EU membership
Prime Minister David Cameron decided to
have one-on-one meetings with
influential mep s in Brussels instead of
the previously agreed meeting with
presidents of all political groups my
feeling is that David Cameron is
strongly convinced that he can convince
the people in Great Britain to vote for
a yes for Europe in a way that defending
British interests is part of Europe and
staying in European family is better for
Britain I think what he wanted to avoid
with the circus where there will be
other people there who clearly whatever
David Cameron says it would never
support him and so he wanted a far more
constructive meeting once an agreement
is found in the council and one the
legal text of the Commission's are on
the table the European Parliament will
take immediately it on board and start
the legislation legislative process and
that we try to be as fast as possible
and as constructive as necessary but
quite clear I can't give a guarantee for
outcome of a future legislation the only
two men who gain something from a black
seed are mr farage and mr. Putin because
the aim of both of them is to divide
euro frm 00 t amo de tu tu veux que el
parlamento roper obviou you old eco
legisladores su questa matera wind e
dopo referendum west a Monsieur de Bono
Ezra's Aminata a DCC decoder concealer
obey a dull parliamentary bell whatever
is decided during the summit there are
fears it might set a precedent for other
countries to follow